I do not think that there is a
contradiction to being gay and
Republican although you know when
stories are written it's usually the
headline gay Republican and I understand
why many leaders of the Republican Party
have led the effort of gay bashing
certainly here in California going back
into the 70s when I got involved it has
been the Republican elected officials
along with a few kind of minder
celebrities who have really really been
the major offenders in this the you know
looking back in history it was Abraham
Lincoln the first Republican president
who freed 4 million slaves in this
country Theodore Roosevelt is who's my
political hero you know he was the most
progressive Republican he's the first to
invite a black to the White House he was
for women's suffrage he was the one who
really led the way in civil rights 100
years ago and you know so so I'm trying
to bring the Republican Party back to
its roots of Lincoln and Roosevelt
because I think it's so important it's
gotten hijacked by a few far-right
individuals that abuse the the gay issue
to win elections and that's wrong and
and I hope to set that record straight
by by considering running for president
myself and it's it's you know there's
there's a lot of basis to the Republican
Party which is still very prevalent in
this country you know less government
whereas you know that that's
contradictory to some of our leaders but
the government should stay out of our
private lives and that's a Republican
philosophy they claim in the last
election in the midterms at 31% of the
gay community voted Republican 25
percent you know in the time before so I
just hope that that there's balance I
think the Republican Party has a lot of
good people it's it's a little tough
because of the leadership but but on the
Don't Ask Don't Tell repeal we had eight
United States senators courageously
stand up and and and you know stand up
to their leadership to repeal that
discriminatory law five more in the
House of Representatives so we're taking
baby steps there but I hope to help
significantly in bringing the Republican
Party to
party at once was as a leader in civil
rights in this country